the center looking for images that you fought
total it is already part of your visual memory
this is a series that calls mega pixels
in magazine photos right
and it is precisely you trying to create a
win situation recreating a
technological solution with content that already exists
but when  you come across it on a
large scale you will start to
realize that this image made of thousands
of pieces of another image
you will be subject to a series of
small ones for the bids that you are
always trying to recover and negotiate
this relationship between the detail is  that the
entirety of the image
the first thing when you look at an
image study it once the door the
party decided we start trying to
look in magazines a little then
grab rip pages create a
situation where this origin of these
small images doesn't look like  you
can identify a singular source
where the images are coming from the idea of
y being able to make a whole song with small
break  ininhos, right, support it with your hand
to avoid from another one,
in addition, I use the scanner that gives me
an image with a resolution of a few
gigapixels
this will be the final scale on this scale
you can also see the ref tony is the
plot of these images that they were the
company  the fact that they were printed
with very low resolution
you are seeing at the same time something
very clear and very out of focus
this ambiguity is very interesting
only
the sound